this morning we're learning about Jeff
Bezos his ambitious plans to send humans
to the moon and beyond and the vehicle
to get us there the Blue Origin and
Amazon founder unveiled this the design
for his blue moon spacecraft yesterday
the lunar lander has been under
development for three years it comes
less than two months after the White
House announced its goal of returning to
the moon
mark Strassmann shows us the vision for
blue moon billionaire Jeff Bezos his
next venture is literally out of this
world
it's time to go back to the moon this
time to stay at a presentation in
Washington DC the Amazon founder and CEO
on Thursday unveiled a mock-up of blue
moon a lunar lander Bezos says will
ferry Rovers cargo and eventually people
to the moon in space resources we have
to use them the project would mark the
first ever commercial moon landing a
very fundamental long-range problem is
that we will run out of energy on earth
this is just arithmetic it's going to
happen the first manned moon landing
happened 50 years ago this July
astronauts haven't been back since 1972
Bezos insists blue moon will be ready in
time to meet the Trump administration's
new goal in space returning American
astronauts to the moon by 2024 NASA must
meet that new spirit with new urgency to
meet that demand
NASA is turning to private companies
like bezos's Blue Origin last year NASA
awarded Blue Origin 13 million dollars
to support its lunar lander NASA
Administrator Jim bridenstine says
developing such a vehicle is one of the
biggest challenges lunar landers are
difficult to build they take time they
take money and we don't have that
capability the moon suddenly seems
closer again for CBS this morning I'm
mark Strassmann
fascinating indeed but to go to the moon
and stay I don't think so Jeff let's
stay right here and you just track what
you all are doing up there cheering you
on cheering you on that I don't want to
go and stay